and the price is of course great because
it's free this week I'm not recommending
a book Premier Wen already did that but
instead I want you to go back to school
for free and you don't have to leave
home this school is called the Khan
Academy it's an online crack classroom
started by former hedge fund manager Sal
Khan Khan makes videos of lessons about
everything from algebra to venture
capital and everything in between 2,000
lessons in all mostly math and science
which have been watched 18 million times
Bill Gates watches them with his kids I
want to recommend just to get you
started for particular lessons one on
the French Revolutions one on so-called
cupcake economics because one on the
Geithner plan 2.5 and one on that math
problem that vexed all of us in high
school the passing bicycle uva take a
look at this clip how many minutes after
an her eyes at point B will Betty arrive
at Point a so betty was going in this
direction they meet right here and then
she keeps going in hits point a didn't
get it in high school you will now go to
our website for links to the lessons i
particularly liked but they're really
all good and now for the last look